the we all know stable marriages and
turns out a lot of interesting fact
about cases you need some of the stuff
we've heard from the previous two
speakers pollination that i'm going to
present contrast with other analysis
that we've done that's like for example
random ranking this joint work was a
sign whose over there the other one is
look at waiting dating sites or ride
hailing the room renting or any of these
traumatic market and you know there is
two sided in that there's somebody
selling something somebody buying
something and then their ranking each
other in terms of preferences right so
you you go to one of these sites and
you'll see some examples and this fits
into a metric space formulation and both
in the continuous and discrete senses
there are connecting previous results
and i'll review that as we go along so
here's an example if you go to okcupid
you answer sort of binary questions like
this okay I your morning person could
you date somebody who was really messy
you like scary movies right it's looking
disgusting it's jealousy healthy in a
relationship right so you basically
answers binary questions and then you as
the entrant have your binary vector and
another person has their binary vector
now it sort of makes sense to look at
what Hamming distance right how many
things do you agree on that's an example
right so that sort of automatically
comes in here but you can think of like
your listing a property on Airbnb and
somebody's trying to say i want to go to
the Olympics and i want to look for a
house that's close to public transit or
to these particular events locations for
these events like swimming only i'm very
interested in that so there's a
preference as people are expressing
right that's the idea here's the
formulation so let's say there are n men
and women and each person answers a
binary
binary questions and so their answer
vectors take values in 0 1 to the K and
you think of distances between two these
vectors tingo hamming distance which
I've already mentioned I'm where it is
another metric where you look at the
coordinates are sort of weighted in
having distance all coordinates matter
equally this one let's say the
coordinate it could be a deal-breaker if
you like cats and she doesn't owe the
other way around okay so that's what it
means to you know and whether the
favorite color is blue or red maybe less
important okay so that's that's sort of
how you should into a second metric and
you'll see if you don't think of it like
that then you know okcupid shouldn't be
in business you know that is the
question here is how many questions we
need to answer before I find the right
person for me okay and metrics matter so
each map issue moon ranks the men by
distance from closest to farthest and
vice versa and where there are ties
which happens in discrete spaces you
break them randomly we go give this and
it's naturally how we do it okay we
don't sort of flip coins typically but
you know there's a nice wonderful model
but some of these practical questions
especially is matching markets leak this
formulation actually I'm going to just
assume every every one of you every one
of us know stable matching so I'm not
going to spend too much time reviewing
it in ride hailing for example is very
similar there are people who want cars
and there are cars running around
available to be hired and here the
metric is naturally something like
Euclidean distance it's a good proxy for
time to pick up okay but if we talk to
guys like folks who do this for a living
a ruber it's not so much that for a
given person how many cars are nearby
and what's the time to pick up the
orientation the vehicles on the streets
matter not that they're necessarily in a
one-way street but actually the
orientation the way color a two-way
street matters okay you can you can do
this for amusement like a new york city
where you live you can do not you you
you know you're in boston so CEO Mike
lives in New York City your collaborator
sorry so if you stand there an opening
over app on one-way street or wait until
the car is just part
too because I got can't turn around and
then I asked sometimes I got to get
assigned to you meanwhile there's a guy
behind on the right side of you from
streets perspective but they won't get a
sign because they're not quite yet
including distance is still ruling this
world okay you can do this just for
amusement in this guide take eight
minutes to go round round round and come
back okay where is this guy could have
been assigned to in three minutes ok so
this sort of a thing you know how
seriously interesting practical
consequences when you think of these
problems right here's a list so it's
very most of the so this is the web 3.2
world right one point 0 is all the
information it works two pointers well
two pointers information networks and
social networks and so on but this is
the third generation so lots of stuff
being bought and sold in these different
places so what I'm presenting to you is
actually proven early analysis you'll
see that there's a lot of things that
you know either very obvious what what
further work looks like when it consists
of stable matching zinda screen
continuous metric spaces we're going to
consider the discrete space i showed you
with the two distances that I've given
you and then for continuous spaces we're
going to look at the Euclidean distance
on are you can look at higher dimensions
as well in your mind's you can already
start thinking of this as you don't have
to think of particular spaces like you
know 0 1 to the K like the hypercube we
could also think or the real line if you
think of just a points on a graph and
Men ours on some vertices and women are
somewhere over the sea so sometimes in
same vertex and then you or use the
graph distance number of hops for
example to match okay and that models
also thinks where it really is you know
a lot of these guys were online stores
like think of Alibaba flipkart or
someone or even amazon if you want to
sell a certain brand of shirt and you
don't have the purple colored version of
it in San Francisco no point in showing
you the San Francisco guys because
there's going to cost you a lot of money
to ship it from let's say a layout then
whatever it is that you have it in stock
ok so this locational thing matters so
that's
questions are compa when is it a unique
stable match because now we're not sort
of flipping coins that's what I mean
rather we are ranking each other based
on preferences or hopefully things
should be unique more easily okay
without resorting tiebreaks what is the
probability that the woman matches with
the top choice it's also hopefully
improves because I've taken the trouble
to answer all this questions so
hopefully in what I mean when the random
ranking list case even in the man
optimal so the end men and women all the
ranking lists are drawn uniformly random
from set of all permutations in that
case the even the man optimal matching a
man doesn't get his top choice the
choice to start you know where the man
optimal matching matches you with is men
get match to somebody Ron rough we log
in on their preference list okay so
hopefully here because all those
preferences you should do better okay
and also how many questions are need to
answer continuous model there's been
previous work by Holroyd Perez shrawan
another person I guess you should say 33
names in the at all a little hospice I
don't remember the name okay but you
they've considered matching poison
points both in modern higher dimensions
on the rail line you know how r 2 etc
and then the question is what's the
distance you look at our stabling
matched pair pick and pick an edge of
random from the stable matching and ask
for said what's the expected distance
etc okay so here we're going to look at
this in the unbalanced case where the
the Poisson process of different rates
so this is just useful to review the
most important thing is this last
definition when there are multiple
stable matchings for a person and let's
say a man and woman are matched and at
least one stable matching then they're
going to be called stable partners so a
man can have multiple civil partners in
YC versa so that's a quantity of
interest a very nice paper by Patel is
actually a couple of papers where he
showed the average number of stable
matchings when the random when the
ranking was so drawn at random is this
quantity it's like n log n roughly and
then I'm the average number of stable
partners his login so you actually had
lots of stable lodgings and lots of
stable partners a surprising result by
sloggi at all recently is that if you
have even just one additional person of
the opposite gender they could sort of
vastly reduce the number of stable
partners it's not clear yet how many how
the collapse has set of stable matchings
what surely does but you know it hasn't
been quantified but this is already very
interesting surprising it seems like you
know some some some sort of imbalance
makes a choice go away in one case not
so nice way in the other case nice way
suppose in the short supply just
benefits let's look look at our
situation where we have I'm going to
start with 0 1 to the K and then with
Hamming distance I'm just going to
quickly walk through what happens when K
equals 1 okay initially each man so
let's walk to the algorithm each man a
woman has independent and random ranking
list just to begin with and then they
each person picks a 0 or 1 okay
and a man who picks 0 lose all the women
who pick 0 to the top of his ranking
list leaving the daughter unchanged
Silesia Leah ranked all the women
randomly and orders n women some number
pick n 0 let's say picked 0 and whatever
they are in his ranking list he moves
them all ahead of all the guys who
picked one leaving everybody else's you
live in the 0 the ordering between them
unchanged and the or in between ones
unchanged will be okay with this so the
tiebreaking run is implicit similarly
the men do the same thing men who picked
one do the same thing and their women
too and with ranking lease or rearrange
we look for stable matchings okay the
number of again walking through this
right number of men whooping 0 is n over
2 plus minus square root of okay so if
you look at all the men who picked 0
roughly half of them will pick it but
there's this fluctuation now let's
assume without loss of generality that
men picking 0 is smaller the number of
them is smaller than the number of women
picking 0 so this is in the unbalanced
case for all the men who pick 0 the fear
of them then the women who pick 0 so
send some number let's say k and k plus
AB okay so these guys you know the run
ranking list are still random once you
know you conditioned on this and the ex
laga told us I will apply and then
you'll get the number of stable partners
for these guys a goes to one with high
probability okay as n goes to same thing
will happen if you apply so if the
number of men who picked 10 sorry is
smaller than the number of women who
pick 0 then the opposite is true for the
ones because total adds up to an right
and still legs random in the same exact
thing will apply then that leaves us
with the men who picked one and the
women of big zeros to learn matched well
they look at each other but that is also
still random right that is this is the
residue of the phase one of the
algorithm and the Patel results will
apply
and you have multiple civil partners and
matchings as quantified by Patel the
conclusion is 44 caicos on there's no
uniqueness the stable matchings and
tiebreaking is needed to get it stable
partners so the question is you know how
far do I need to go with k so k is login
okay that's a natural place to ask
because now you're you know caicos login
means you have to tooth decay or you
know the number of answer actresses and
order n right and it still doesn't help
because the Hamming distance I just need
to agree with you on some you know if
you have to random binary vectors of
length K they will regret off Leon fifty
percent of their entries Plus this
fluctuation it really doesn't help okay
yet so caicos login is insufficient you
can get that result on the positive side
we can go as far as if you're willing to
go as far as K equals n to the six login
you can show first of all the ranking
list can be strictly ordered using
Hamming distances that imply that
there's unique stable matching but we
think the answer somewhere closer to its
all into the sixth again this is where
you know a slightly okcupid one survived
because that's way too many questions
and but it is a pleasing thing which is
that each man or woman will be matched
to the top choice with probability at
least fifty percent okay that's great on
the one hand which is completely false
otherwise like in the random ranking
this case this is this property zero so
sketch of proof let's just look at what
how this first thing plays out part one
so let's say stay k equals log and
therefore specifically N equals 2 to the
K so now we're thinking of some you know
K dimensional hypercube and I'm dropping
and men and women on the vertices of
this higher dimensional hypercube K
dimensional hypercube and so since there
are exactly n vertices and I'm dropping
and men randomly and women randomly it's
like I'm dropping to end balls into n
bins where you know one is let's say
colored blue in the other ones color red
the there's a positive probability that
there of there's a positive density of
bins with exactly two men and two women
in them yeah that's easy to see and
because we're matching based on distance
so probability there are two stable
matchings because once you fall in the
same place I still have to break the
ties randomly you can work this out the
probability that you know in the
two-by-two case that the two stable
matchings right is one or eight you can
work the sound okay so there's a
positive density of so a person can at
least two stable partners with positive
probability so this log and doesn't
suffice already but more interesting
thing is that they're exponentially many
stable matchings because there's a
positive density of bins that have the
possibility of two stable matchings
that's enough to get you and they're
randomly you're right so you can see how
they really see the exponential right on
some vertices on several vertices there
are at least two stable matching is
possible and which way they flip you
know either the the through stable
matching or the cross stable matching is
independently done so you have
exponentially many matchings
civil magicks ok so login doesn't work
but you know as I said and the six login
will walk but for the strong reason
listed in bullet one which is that you
can uniquely order all all the people
okay though there won't be any
coincidences in distances okay so this
is where the uniform metric is
interesting not all questions are
equally you know important or there's
some serious deal breaker questions and
if you look at that metric then
Nationals cake was follow again you will
get this property of the rank English
being able you know you can order them
uniquely and then there's a unique
stable matching okay and I'm going to go
to the continuous case do any questions
for me right now there are the
generalizations I will come to this is
an interesting thing i've never seen a
chair show remove our mobile phone
announcement or how many minutes are
left so stealing's on the line
unbalanced poised on matchings so here
you know let's take this ride hailing
application because it is in a sense
roughly canonical okay then maybe other
places are feeling the renting the
property rental thing is certainly some
people want to stay close to work there
are the metrics that play a role but
this very direct you can look at a
two-way street okay so that means a car
can be picked up ok a car can pick up a
hailer on it's right or on its left yes
allowed okay or you can look at the
one-way street okay the reason I'm
showing this is that this is exactly
certain type of Q like a stack type Q
and you can analyze this I mean the
analysis of this is known so and this
implies bounds on this very
straightforward okay and so the model
itself looks like there are blue points
which are poised on with rate lambda and
red points with great poise on with rate
mu think of a mewling mu
cheaper than lambda okay and here's a
stable matching here's what it looks
like the two-sided thing you can match a
blue point can match either with the
left on the red or on the right
depending on who was closest and
available if match width wasn't been
taken yet it's not hard to see that the
unique matching on the realize not hard
to see and there's a simple algorithm
put in the hole put out in the hall
right paper which is actually nice the
every point shoots out arrows raised
that emanate from these points growing
at unit speed with time and if a ray
hits from a blue point it's a red point
that is hasn't been taken yet then
they're the right guys to match okay
this blu ray hits so for example this
blu ray starts one on this side one on
this side but I'm it comes to read this
read got taken because an earlier time
this guy got there that means going and
gets this okay and you can see the sound
of them terminates pretty
straightforward so let's pick a blue
point at random and look at the distance
which partner on the line let's call it
a matching distance now we're interested
in how is this random variable
distribute it okay in particular or as
expectation is bra so its exact
distribution if you can get it so the
lambda equals view like I said there's
this paper by Holroyd at all from 2009
where they show in the one dimension
case expected value of square root of x
is infinite and as you go to higher
dimensions you get good moments okay
this is infinite but they can show it's
yucky in other words expected value of x
is finite but at a higher value of T
it's not that's that's what this is okay
sorry I didn't tell you when it was
finite okay this is just showing when
it's infinite okay let's make this point
I made earlier about let's start looking
at the unbalanced case and I'm going to
consider one-sided matching problem so
my blues are still rest and rape and
Fire Reds but i'm going to stipulate
that loose can only match with Reds on
the right if a red is available to you
that's closer to you like for example
let's let's think of taxis or cars as
blues and passengers as Reds this guy
has somebody here but the street is
going this way so you can't pick that
person up ok this is guys to pick up
this person ever to achieve this this is
exactly it is just is isomorphic to
Alaskan for Supreme two regimes
identical ok it's not it's not difficult
to see but you know the way you should
think of it is like you know let's
assume that this is the arrival to such
a queue and before this was served
another arrival showed up so this one
takes precedence and before this course
are another rival showed up so this
takes precedence over this and hence
that and then this got served and then
this came up to the top of the stack and
he'd got server and song do you see this
right so the last thing about this last
come closer for Q exact everything is
known about it everything possible ok
it's table when lambda is less than mu
arrival rate is smaller service rate
it's stable and you know all sorts of
quantities ok so now here's the formal
definition well this just just wanted to
use one term you called the busy cycle
is the amount of time that the queue is
actually busy continuously which in this
case is when a customer arrives it
starts the instant this customer arrives
and then arrives an empty queue
then stops the business cycle stops only
when the person departs right so think
of a blue that arrives in an empty queue
they start a busy cycle and the business
cycle ends when the blue leaves and
write the second thing is because its
last confessor okay this so everything
is known in particular this mean is 1
over mu minus lambda so we're going to
have some occasion to return to this
particular value so here the theorem for
our two-sided matchings random variable
x which we were interested in it
stochastically dominates the minimum of
this B 1 and B 1 prime which I'll tell
you what they are they're actually the
distributor has the busy cycle of this
cube okay so this is busy cycle is Q and
then let bi be distributed as I ID bi
and bi prime as deciding for this Q and
is in turn dominated by the maximum of
these things where again these are same
be eyes but these n 1 and n 1 prime are
just geometry independent geometries
random variables okay so this is bound
bound looks you know on the one hand is
encouraging to have balance the other
hand say well let me just completely
expected value and say how does that
look so as a corollary of this upper
bound you can did you can get this
result that says the expected value is
bounded by this quantity okay but then
you can separately prove to a
combinatorial argument okay well which
is the song one is quite interesting as
is this bound quite interesting okay
just mathematically what's interesting
in its workers
you can actually get this better bound
okay but we actually conjecture so keep
in mind that so this is the two-sided
stable matching and we're now saying
that you and your stable partner are not
suffered by more than two over mu minus
lambda whereas for the one side stable
matching we already saw that that that
value is 1 over mu minus lambda I call
attention to right so just doesn't sound
right that the two-sided guy is worse
than the one-sided guy okay this is just
more choice so we know this bound is
loose but in further think about it
let's just see what happens in the limit
as mu gets very large what does that
mean there are these blue points and
they're trying to match with a red point
either closest point of the left or
right depending on availability but the
number of Reds is increasing that's what
it means for the mutant you to keep on
going let's see it's going to infinity
at some point for every red point you'd
like to match with the blue on the left
or a blue on the right I mean there's
going to be one sorry for every blue
point I apologize for every blue point
when the number of Reds is very high
there's going to be somebody immediately
to his left or right as here to match
with okay so we expect that this is
actually much better than this number
okay and in fact it should look
asymptotically something like 1 over 2
mu for the same reason I just told you
okay
and we conjecture that this is the case
so you can actually reduce this bound by
a factor of four it hasn't been done yet
and you can just see this even holds up
in simulation and it does okay so that's
for the distances and how they're you
know how far they need to go to find
somebody okay but what about the how far
are there on your ranking list so as we
saw for the Hamming distance you'll
match with the top choice likely fifty
percent chance what about here for the
one pilots one-sided matching everything
about this is known everything right
because I I'm a I'm an arrival I come to
a queue now whether I matched my first
you know the next service token through
I would release me or the one after that
or the one off that just comes down to
whether there's an arrival after me or
the service arrives before that they ok
this and that's exactly equal to MU
which is rid of the service divided by
mu plus lambda this is rate of both
Allah right and so everything is known
for the queue so for the last compressor
q this probability is exactly mu divided
by mu plus lambda and you expect that
you should do better in the two-sided
case and what is it showing is that's
true x axis muse increasing y axis is
what's the probability of matching with
your top choice for that given mu
holding lambda at one so you see that
this is for the two-sided problem and is
the one side problem and obviously to
sign is better okay
and so there's an obvious lower bound
which you can use but again you have to
establish that that the bound is
actually mathematically correct you sort
of think where is this would be obvious
but you anything oh there must be some
coupling somewhere we have found this
okay so it's very interesting okay
problem and I want to conclude by just
saying that you know this stable
matching submit in metric spaces in
natural and the capsules buyer seller
preferences I also think in terms of
practical applications you know the
ability exists here for looking
repeatedly I don't mean the dating case
hopefully not dating like like you're
buying goods on amazon okay just you
know five times a week or something okay
but just think of you know when
someone's repeatedly visiting and as
preferences are being understood and
revealed my feelings that this actually
you know there's some this is a
component of learning to this preference
listen to keep deferring okay that's
useful to understand alone and we've
seen that theory differs pretty
significantly from what happens to write
random ranking this case and therefore
it's worth you know looking at this
further we've seen some basic stuff in
this discrete model ooh nice to sort of
think more generally but also extend
this to general graphs and unbalanced
point process matching some high
dimensional spaces I think at the moment
I think of this is like sort of
interesting theoretically but who knows
right when I remember you all Perez
telling me frozen poised on matching
take a look at this paper and I did and
it never occurred to me that has
anything to practice at the time but
obviously it does it's alright Haley so
I think Paris and I'll wrote this paper
in 2009 by lubal started in 2009 they
didn't know about each other
it happened to be the case so i think
the incorporating monetary and economic
considerations actually this is what i
meant by when you see something
happening repeatedly it's very
interesting so there's an imbalance
there's more taxes than passengers or
the other way around the sears economic
implications and putting the outer
pricing loop on this sort of matching
problem is very useful okay i think that
is where actually that's what hussein
and i started with can we model all this
and then wait a minute and then we got
you know so you sort of peel the
amendment coming now and we need to put
the lid other less backing okay thanks
let's take the questions offline let's
thank us all the speakers of the session